hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Logitech or episode 9 video
big b-day de Star Wars trailer Nucor
episode everyone truly happy Black
Friday craziness
definitely get a big surprise in terms
of a really significant character we
weren't sure was going to be back
and kinda found out like where team
Korea is going to be going in the next
couple that Assad's
I've also got info on when they're going
to be airing the final episodes
it's gonna be a two-part finale not
four-part equitably before
soul explain that the end the video with
matter to you ran to the Wizards now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but
cable responders in case you haven't
seen the episode starting with top by
moments
number five dispute by and capture right
you his tour group engine or a
thing and it is most about the whole
tour group scene was
all the questions that photographer was
asking is like you the audience you know
just questioning the logic that Mike
unbranded setup
another when they're able to poke fun at
themselves that they have characters ask
the questions that the fandom is asking
it's also a dick catch people up and
remind everyone who'd didn't remember
about part two in last season
are people whose get season to all
together seems like this
like this kinda comedy is what I miss
most about cora are one of the things
I'm gonna miss most
number four opal and a phone are going
to lead a mission
to get their family back sobils freaking
out
papon basically gives her the business
it says we gonna do this ourselves
I recently broke boleyn now into he
definitely looks like he had that look
at determination on a space like
okay I'm gonna be serious bowling now I
don't know that we're gonna end the
season
with team core completely split up but
it seems like for at least the next
episode or two
they're going on the side mission is out
too and that might be how top gets
brought back into the story
I was kinda disappointed we didn't see
in this episode because we physically
were not in the Earth Kingdom or
anywhere near the swap I think that's
why didn't include her
I think want they travel to South who
like for this rescue mission
then we'll see top again but will be
near the swap and we'll get another shot
aku Kira
number three core explains what could be
a is doing with this beard fines
in the world leaders start to deal with
their I like the core got there like
just is Boleyn and Barry
were running in now everyone pretty much
knows what the deal is with could be
related building this giant weapon
even though they didn't reference by two
know those interesting betting you're a
specific they just said
big blow ERP weapon you know like the
most non scientific explanation for a
super weapon that you possibly give
someone
and clearly none the world leaders are
taking cora seriously
she claims that is because your ass
handed to her by Cu Vera
but honestly I think that Michael was
never really hot honor so he prolly
woulda done this no matter what
even if she had got defeated really
recently Rachael is in a bad person
but he is an antagonised the most fun
part though is just shot a busy me where
she gave the look
I knew she was gonna have a speaking
part at some point we didn't know it was
gonna come but when I sorrows like
bodies it's gonna be in the scene
if they're just teasing us the like nope
macular speak yet
I don't know that they can explain who
her mother is like who's who goes by
is before the end of the series might be
there for the comics but whoever she was
I'm sure she was more the more practical
choices and a lot of people think that
it's made
but I think that they broke up in the
comics it someone has been a little
while ago
about general I wrote like that Branson
I wrote becoming filers some point I
don't think that she's going to be at
getting any time soon like she doesn't
look like an elderly person she seems
like she's
you know relatively late 40's 50's still
has like a long time to go before she
gives up being
our Lord she said that she's not taking
the Fire Nation into the war
just because you so sick at the legacy
the 100 you weren't all the trouble I
caused
I don't blame her but clearly with the
teasing is that cool beer is going to do
something is going to force her into the
war
is a lot like the United States during
World War Two that they didn't get
involved
didn't get a volatile pearl harbor
happened to the Japanese bombed Pearl
Harbor
in that basically inside it every want
to just push Congress to declare war
that's why I think something crazy is
going to happen with your super weapon
makes you can either
attacked the Fire Nation in some way or
do something that's so crazy that
izumi says we have to join the war now
but it really will end up being like
everyone verses could be read a certain
point but I think it's gonna be on cora
to solve everything Michael be on her to
resolve the issue
and I don't think it's going to end with
them killing cool Europe other way to
get a chance here
and he is awfully Murray number two core
reconnects
with Robert so jumping for just a little
bit cora
basically need to get over herself she
is like some sort of mental block in
place
like her body is fine her powers are
intact is mentally she's
preventing herself from accessing her
abilities I liked the years concept that
her abilities are limitless
and given the think he's done
I think that he's right based on her
accessing her powers in the spirit world
which previously was thought to be
impossible
I think that she's going to have some
sort of like super energy bending moment
that will involved her removing Cougars
powers but I do think that you might use
them to somehow bind the physical on the
spirit realms together are somehow keel
their connection
typically when I think about the
connection between the spirit realm in
the physical realm
I think about the Banyan Grove tree but
that's like the backbone up both
realities
so I think that the resolution one bob
cora doing something with the tree
then supposedly those vines if they're
connected in Republic City run through
the entire world
each season like around this time
there's a moment work or comes to some
sort of
realization about her abilities or about
the world itself
she gets knowledge she needs to defeat
the bill and or
solve whatever big problem there is
presumably she has the power to deal
with kubera
she's need to develop a plan so I think
we're gonna see with that is in the next
couple episodes
and a bitch is gonna figured out right
away Korean Won others figured out
right away can people she kinda figured
that out as she goes along which is what
you get your butt kicked so often
and PIN number one WTF moment cora visit
the here
in prison so the biggest moment for me
was in so much
cora coming to her big realization
spiritually and mentally
it was actually just going to visit the
year and his reaction to her
he's so chill like the best dawns are
chill like that all the time
too so creepy another their kind
implying that he discovers all the time
in because he's so connected to the
spirit will he probably knew that she
was coming along time ago
although he said it was a little bit
fuzzy in the spirit realm like he only
heard that the Avatar hadn't been there
in a long time
I mean really interested to see if he
plays a role in the finale of course
that she's not going ever forget what he
did but she has color to deal with it a
little bit
her she has little better context now
there was a lot of cora bending in this
episode
like the way that she bended the spear
portals back in book two
Mike and Brian said that that resolution
will not involve
abandon contest that could just mean
that it's not going to involve a fight
the fight to the death was not gonna be
like ain't verses Oside
because I was really with the book 3
finale was like but it is possible but
cora could
you know somehow bend the planet or do
something really crazy because in her
abilities are limitless
the alleged implies she's going to do
something crazy at
pic so I think she will have some sorta
bending moment
but it won't be a fight they maybe
should has been the entire world tree
make should just been the tree all over
the planet at the same time or something
crazy like something on that level let
me know that what was your favorite
moment
and how do you think the Fire Nation is
going to be drawn into the conflict
I feel like that's a pretty good teaser
but the minute Izumi said I'm not gonna
deal with another pointless war
I feel like that's right saying yes
she's definitely going to be in this war
pretty soon
all its gonna take it like some big WTF
demonstration with the weapon
orkut beer attacking the Fire Nation in
some way so frog in the episode a B-plus
mean it was great to bring the hear back
I love the journey the corner is on
you know if you like a lot of people
yell at her for that moment the robber
had where she said
I've always been here it's like happen
is taken for this long to figure that
out
it's really all about herself down like
he is the most self doubting avatar
that we've seen BMT nominee avatars just
to give her the benefit of the doubt
though
was the time when we see that past
avatars there like in their adult form
like it had a long time to figure things
out
and they're very headstrong like you she
who just like I'm minute crush
everything across my problems I think
that's what everyone wants seek or do
the really it's all about that the hear
speech there are no boundaries
no limitations except the ones you
create for yourself if you like that's
gonna be the most important legacy
up like these last episodes in if
nothing else it'll definitely give the
fanfiction
to some crazy places to go i'm happy
with our opal
always locals character you like a soft
addition to Team Avatar like you don't
see her as much as you see Asami
but she's every bit as important because
it is so important to Bowlin
she really is like his call to action
and I didn't mention it during my top
five moments but
pyrrhic in Asami working together those
issue in my predictions
I meet their basically like that to take
his people that we know about
in Republic City so course they're going
to try and develop a countermeasure to
the super weapon
as I me was looking at that magazine
with the big engine on it so I think
that very
is going to engineer a larger EMP like
he did back when they were trying to
escape the Earth Kingdom
it sounds more complicated than it is
but that's something that we use
unlike thousands and thousands at max so
I think Braco
is going to take on Cu Vera she's gonna
marcher Army honor policy at some point
with the weapon
in and that will provide them their
opportunity to use that giant empo
whatever it is they're gonna
then I still feel like we're going to
get some sort of greasy Death Star
moment
where all the ron is destroyed all run
in this case could either be is out to
or could be top work even be the Bhangra
tree something precious
is Polly going to be destroyed and
that's what's going to incite the rest
of the world to war
in the core is gonna have to rush in and
calm everyone down before everything is
destroyed
just in general green episode I think a
room with little disappointed with the
clip show last week so my brain said
this is like the last episode before
the bike is in their words they said who
gets real which kind of a funny way to
talk about it
but basically the last four episodes you
can consider like almost a poor part
finale other technically it's gonna be a
two-part finale
just explain it scheduled so there's
going to be one new episode every week
December 19 though there's going to be
two episodes the last two
absurd 12 and 13 I will continue to burn
experience to feel free to leave
recommendations
and I am doing a Q&A for tomorrow so
please leave all your questions in the
comments
what's gonna happen with this rescue
missions out to work or is going to do
about could be ra
welcome vera is gonna do to the Banyan
Grove tree with that super weapon
and what president Broncos gonna do in
terms of this you know
big global conflict in a political way
just a quick reminder new mobile links
appear to seems the link that over here
but click here for that start rather
tell me what's it like 10 more times
in click here for the CUNY video I that
tomorrow thank you so much watching
slaughterhouses high five
and think about how happy we are that we
got Star Wars in Chora
on the same Black Friday